- Here is Denver, Colorado's
top fine dining establishment,
the Buckhorn Exchange.
It tells you everything you
need to know about the city,
guns, whiskey, taxidermy.
Yes, this is Denver in a nutshell.
God bless the West.
Okay, okay, the city is
actually nothing like this.
It's mostly like this,
sunshine even in the winter,
stoners and non-stoners,
uniting in their celebration
of the great outdoors.
Enjoy.
- Go, D. Park.
- Oh, hi.
I didn't see you there.
Normally at this part of the program,
I would be walking through
the front door of a startup,
but on today's episode, we cannot do that
for this startup wants to remain secret
because its nerds are making a smart gun.
That Navy SEAL you see before you
is holding a gun made by Biofire.
Its very, very big claim is
that it's the first company
to make a smart gun that actually works.
That's right, James Bond style,
fingerprint and facial recognition.
The gun only fires if the
right person is holding it.
- It knows somebody's holding onto it
but no matter how much
he pulls the trigger,
nothing's going to happen because
the system is not unlocked
- The person who started
Biofire is Kai Kloepfer.
He's only 25 years old,
and has been working on
making this gun for 10 years.
A project he started shortly
after the Aurora theater shooting.
- At the time, it's like the
worst mass shooting in history
and happened right just down the road here
from where I grew up.
I was fortunate enough to not have to
think about gun violence or gun deaths,
and that was really my
first, sort of, encounter
with the topic, right?
I was just starting to grow up,
just starting to think
about these kind of topics
as a 15-year-old
and really starting to think about
how could we do something about this.
I started thinking about this
concept of smart gun, right?
And by no means am I the first person
to think about this obviously
and it's been in science fiction forever,
but nobody had ever really
built a working smart gun.
- Okay, so you're 15
and instead of doing some policy,
you're inspired
- I was never a policy person.
- Okay, you're like, "I'm an engineer."
- I've been forced to become
a little bit more of one,
you know, over the last 10 years.
But no, I was an engineer.
I was a socially awkward nerd.
- A bonafide nerd who
clinched his nerd bonafides
by getting an award at
the very prestigious
Intel International Science
and Engineering Fair.
So, okay, so for people who don't know,
I mean, this is like no joke.
This is like thousands of
the world's smartest kids.
- Yeah, top.
The year I win, it was the top 1,500
out of over 8 million people
who competed across the year.
- 8 million people, right?
Yeah, like this is the top of the top.
- Yeah, it's as high as it gets,
I think, for the Science Fair world.
At the time, I was mostly
an electrical engineer
and I could sort of fake my way
through some mechanical engineering.
So built a pretty good electrical system
and a really mechanical system,
sort of slapped them together
into this kind of gun-shaped object.
Not an actual firearm in any way.
I wasn't allowed to bring
a gun to the Science Fair,
quite obviously.
- Right.
- Like, I was very surprised by all this.
You know, I'd done a lot of
Science Fair project before,
Three-quarters of the time,
people didn't believe that
I had actually built them.
They thought my parents had did them.
I mean this in the nicest way possible,
Dad, I'm sorry, but
my dad needs help like
turning his iPad on.
We'll take it slow and...
- After 10 years of toil,
Kai is understandably proud
that his business finally
has a product to sell.
Cool.
- After you.
Today, we've got one of
our Mark II prototypes,
production units of the Mark smart gun.
So as soon as I start to interact with it,
I'm going to see those white lights.
The white lights basically
mean that it's active.
It sees that somebody's picked it up
but it hasn't recognized a user yet,
so it's still locked
- To set up the gun,
you register your face and
fingerprints on this device
in less than a minute,
where you can also add
and delete other users.
If you're not registered, nothing.
- Fingerprints are very well-optimized,
very commercially mature.
You don't need a lot of processing power
to run them appropriately.
Facial recognition is a
cutting edge biometric,
which means it requires
orders of magnitude
more processing power.
So where previously we
were able to just use
like little microcontrollers
and things like that
to do fingerprints,
we've had to basically
build an entire computer
hardened for the system,
you know, that works inside of a gun
to be able to run facial recognition
at the speeds that our customers demand.
- I've shot guns before
but I'm far from a gun enthusiast.
In many ways, I'm
Biofire's target audience,
a dad who wants to keep his family safe
but who also thinks having a gun at home
probably ends up more dangerous than good.
Still, old gun or new,
I needed a few pointers.
- I would try to lean forward,
like just like lean into it a little bit.
Ah, yeah, there you go.
- Okay.
- And again, the target's
like less than 10 feet away
so you don't need to worry
too much about aiming.
- Let's not point that out.
- Sorry, the target is
like a 100-plus yards away.
And Ashlee is about to, you know, do a
marksman level sort a shot here.
- Am I cool to try it?
- Yup.
- Whoo
- There you go.
- It still had more kick
than I thought it was going to.
- It's all good.
- It kicks, and from my
experience, it works.
The question is, will it sell?
Several companies have tried
and failed to make a smart gun
because it's really hard to do,
and not just because you're
mixing sensitive electronics
with regular explosions.
Okay, so you've chosen to do a startup
doing this incredibly hard technology,
and then to wade it into like
a Second Amendment sort of issue, right?
- Yup.
- So this is like nightmare.
- Yeah, keeps it interesting.
- That, as Kai has a talent for doing,
is putting the controversy mildly.
Pro-gun folks hate these
things because they fear
that one day the government
will use the existence
of a working smart gun
to ban the dumb ones.
Even flirting with smart guns
leads to death threats
and financial risks.
One of the reasons Biofire's investors
prefer to stay anonymous,
and plenty of anti-gun
folks don't like them
because, you know, they're guns.
For his part, Kai's not
interested in mandating
or even advertising his product.
Biofire, he says, is just
here to provide choices
and maybe save lives.
- The key thing that
we are trying to solve,
which I think we could completely solve,
is children and teenagers
getting access to firearms.
Firearms are now the
leading cause of death
for children and teenagers in America.
They surpassed motor vehicle accidents
for the first time in 2020.
I've never talked to a gun owner who
wanted their kid to find their gun.
And so, we think that by
building technology that,
you know, basically
works with the gun owner
to enforce what they're
already looking to do
allows us to really actually
address that portion of the
challenge of basically
gun deaths in America.
- The final version of Biofire's gun
arrived in April with
this funky sci-fi look.
It's definitely more Halo
than Red Dead Redemption,
but how well it will
sell is anyone's guess.
- We want it to look modern and futuristic
and a little different
than everything else that's
on the market obviously.
- When I saw that one,
it does have a little
sci-fi thing going on.
- Yeah, and again, we don't
want it to look too normal
but we don't want it to
look like only, you know,
something that a sci-fi
nerd would like like myself.
- Like the Cybertruck or something?
- Yeah, I was trying to not say that.
- Have you ever had that thing, man,
where you're hanging out on a bench
and looking at the clouds
and you're like, "There's a dragon.
There's a turtle.
Hey, there's a jellyfish."
Wait, I think that jellyfish
has a camera on it.
I think that jellyfish is watching me.
It is.
- There is a suspected Chinese spy balloon
that's been hovering
over the northern U.S.
- Yes, there was that moment
that the world looked transfixed
upon our visitor from China.
What China didn't know
though was that America
has its own super high
tech balloon program,
able to be launched by
hoodie-wearing dudes
wherever they can find parking.
- We saw a path to finally
make the stratosphere
and stratospheric balloons viable,
this super old technology
that has never really been
able to be become broadly applicable.
- The makers of this fancy balloon,
Andrew and Jared, work here at Urban Sky.
The basic idea is that
high altitude balloons
can be used to capture lots
of imagery of the world,
filling the stratosphere-sized gap
between other aerial options.
You've got drones at one
layer and planes at one layer
and then there's this like
huge jump up to satellites
and there's just kind of
like nothing in between.
- Yeah, I mean we say it sometimes
like we somewhat view ourselves
as like the SpaceX of the stratosphere.
- Urban Sky's images might look
a lot like satellite imagery
but they're much, much more detailed
and can be taken more
cheaply and frequently,
tracking things like wildfires,
the effects of climate change,
and all manner of human activity.
- You can see cars, you can
see features on the roofs,
you can see landscaping,
you can see light posts, power lines.
- These people are worried.
It's not like espionage faces.
- You cannot see a person.
Right, yeah, you cannot see a person.
We have no intention of doing that.
- Yeah.
Both men have serious
history with balloons.
They used to work for World View
which makes massive stratospheric balloons
and also takes pictures with them.
The problem though is that
the balloons are expensive
and take many hours and a
ton of people to launch.
Urban Sky is trying to make
ballooning quick and easy.
- Our big bet was that
sensors and components
would miniaturize to the
point that we could make
very powerful high
resolution imaging systems
in a very lightweight package.
- I know the first time I
described this company to someone,
they're going to be like, "How
do they control this thing?
It's just going to fall in
some city on somebody's head."
You know, I mean, it's
pretty obvious concern.
- Yeah, I mean, at a high
level, we do control it.
So like, it's not a balloon
that's just going to fall
out of the sky and go somewhere random.
We know pretty precisely
exactly what altitude
our balloon will float at.
Then, you can think of it like
where in like the currents of the ocean,
like they're fairly uniform,
that we're moving in a general direction
when we get to a float altitude.
- When it's time to come down,
Mission Control sends a signal
and the balloon gently deflates.
- Nice easy landing.
System's in great condition.
- All right, this is the
balloon-making operation.
- Welcome to the balloon
manufacturing, yeah.
- Yes, they're willing to
show us their balloons,
just not tell us what they're made of.
- Is it like a plastic or?
- Yeah, we can speak to it a little bit.
Some of it is a secret in
terms of what it is, but...
- Can I touch it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, go for it.
- It feels light, which it turns out
is important for a balloon
and everything attached to it.
So this is the moneymaker.
- This is the moneymaker.
This is one of the moneymakers.
So we have several
different imaging payloads
that we operate.
This entire thing you see here
weighs less than six pounds.
This is a wildfire monitoring system,
so the guts of this is basically
a thermal infrared camera.
So NASA and the Air Force
have funded this system,
and we think it'll have a ton of value
for doing early detection of wildfires.
- And in true Colorado
nature-loving fashion,
they also want to make it reusable.
- It was always a little
bit heartbreaking to see
this literal mountain of
thousands of pounds of plastic
get put in a dumpster.
- What's the most you've reused one?
- Three times for one balloon.
So yeah, we can get several
reuses out of a balloon.
- Eventually, we want
to get to the paradigm
where these systems are reusable
the way something like
a parachute is reusable,
where you can use the same
system hundreds of times.
- Okay, let's see this thing
in its natural habitat.
Time for a field trip.
So we found this kind of like
empty little carve out of area
but you guys could just be
on the side of the road or?
- If it's safe and legal to
park, we can launch from there.
- Yeah, you kind of just need
whatever's as big as the truck, right?
- Right.
Ready to fill.
All right, here we go.
- Is there's something you say?
Up, up and away?
Oh, wow.
Is it going to inflate?
Like, it look like a big teardrop or?
- It is, so it's only
about 10% full right now.
- Okay.
- So that gas is expanding
as it gets higher and higher
and the atmosphere gets
less and less dense.
- As the balloon went up and up
like a memory from childhood,
I was dangerously close to
feeling something intimate
about a piece of inflated plastic.
I don't know, probably
just the mountain air.
If you're in Denver itself,
it's all beer and pot
shops and dumb bridges,
tossing some dogs and
joggers, and you get the idea.
Of course what you want to do
is get to the great outdoors.
I mean, this might as well
be me heading to Mordor.
It's weird and beautiful, and
it's everywhere in Colorado.
Colorado's the kind of place
where you can put on some waders,
hop in a stream, and run
into a rocket scientist.
Meet Joe Laurienti,
the CEO of rocket engine
maker, Ursa Major.
- We are on the Big Thompson River,
pretty in the middle of nowhere
as far as Colorado towns go.
This is pretty normal
Colorado fishing experience
that you drive to these rivers,
find a spot to pull off the road,
and go find fish, yeah.
- And what are we going to try to catch?
What's our goal?
- Just some trout. All right.
- All right, man, I'm excited.
- We just want to cast this out
and kind of let the river take it.
- But otherwise the bob's staying on top.
- Yeah, just pull it
out like that, exactly
because you want that yellow line
to go all the way to the end.
So just do that a couple more times, yeah.
And don't be afraid to have too much line.
- I just don't want to hit you.
- There you go, that's perfect.
- Don't lie to me, Joe.
- This is 30 minutes from the office, so.
You don't get that in
a lot of other places.
- Yeah.
And is it, like, changing
as all that Californians
are coming and ...
- I don't tend to notice.
They come help us build rocket engines.
- Yeah.
All right, watch your face.
- All right.
- It's also low risk with
these small trout flies
'cause the hook is like centimeter long.
- Yeah, I'd still feel
bad if I hooked a CEO.
Ursa Major does its work
here in a suburb of Denver,
where it can fire its big loud engines.
- Where we're looking right now is our,
that's two Hadley engines facing us,
so we'll see fire coming right at us.
- Okay.
- Let's see some fire.
- Cool.
- That'll loosen up some seals.
- The world today is
full of rocket startups,
and each one is trying
to make their own rockets
and their own rocket engines.
But as many of them have
learned, engines blow up.
- Okay, you just saw a bright flash there.
- It's what makes
building rockets so hard.
Ursa would like them
to consider a new idea,
"Don't bother making engines.
Buy them from us."
Like I've noticed though,
all these rocket companies
I go to, there is this,
the engine is like it's
like the sexiest part.
It's like-
- It's romantic, yeah.
- Yeah, and it's like we're doing
something big and important,
and everybody wants to
make their own engine
even though it causes all this
suffering and financial ruin.
How do you sort of convince
people to get off that?
- A piece of it is kind of breaking down
that romantic notion.
There are a few reasons
companies buy engines from us.
The most common or the easiest sale is
the make versus buy decision.
If a company is just
starting, they need an engine.
We now have engines available.
That's almost a no-brainer.
We can save them five years,
tens or hundreds of millions of dollars.
The other opportunity is
if there's been a failure,
if you might have...
Maybe it's your first flight,
maybe it's your 50th flight,
if you have a launch failure,
and you're facing down
another five-year engine
development campaign to fix that.
- Right, 'cause if there's a failure,
you have to shut down and
figure out what went wrong.
- Exactly.
- Then come back
and prove that the fix works.
- It's almost an easier story to say
there's a known reliable
engine on the market
that we're switching to versus
diving back into why did our engine fail.
- Is there a fear that the
people who are going to make it
have already kind of made it
and they're already
making their own engines,
and you sort of need these
newcomer rocket companies
that hadn't already made that commitment
and maybe it's too late?
- I think I would have that fear if
NASA and the Air Force and the Space Force
and every commercial
company we're saying today
we are completely happy with
how we're getting to orbit
and capacity is completely met,
but that's absolutely not the case.
- The company is off to a good start
with big orders from several startups,
plus some deals with the Air Force.
They sell a relatively
small rocket engine, Hadley,
for just under a million dollars.
The next size up, Ripley,
is still in development.
- This is a turbo pump
assembly for Ripley.
- Can we, for a moment,
talk nerd out on turbo pumps?
Yes, it's true, I'm an engine geek.
But objectively, Ursa is one
of those badass companies
with badass hardware.
- The turbo pump really powers the engine.
It's the heart of the engine.
Really, you're taking things
from one extreme to another.
So you're taking minus
300 degree liquid oxygen,
you're combusting it to
thousands of degrees,
you're using that to drive
a turbine that needs to go
from zero to tens of thousands of RPMs.
- But like even SpaceX for years
didn't build its own turbo pump.
They had a company build it.
- We've got an incredible
turbo machinery team.
- All made by badass people.
- I'm a big fan of paragliding,
skydiving, and BASE jumping.
- Like propulsion
technician, Margo Vriesinga.
- I love the way this company operates.
I think it's so, it makes so much sense.
The way that we exist allows
other companies to exist.
It's almost funny that it
hasn't happened sooner.
Because you're looking at companies
like Pratt and Whitney or Rolls-Royce,
they're making engines.
Boeing's not making their own engines.
That would be crazy.
That's time-consuming.
That's the hard part, you know?
- You know, technology
overall is notoriously
kind of skews male.
And in my experience,
aerospace companies are
it's like 9 to 1.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, is that weird
or is that changing or?
- There's definitely
significantly more women here
than I'm used to working with.
It's really nice actually
'cause I don't feel like
I'm like in a fishbowl or
some kind of zoo animal.
- And of course for practical reasons,
it has to be here.
This facility is pretty interesting
because most of the places I've been,
if you think about SpaceX
or Blue Origin as examples,
you're building engines in
California or Washington
and then you're going all the way to Texas
to do most of the tests.
You don't have this kind of feedback.
It just, it slows everything down.
We just saw it.
I mean, you can do everything
in just like a few hundred
yards from each other.
- Yeah, it's very unique.
We definitely could not fire engines
like you saw today in Los Angeles.
- Yeah.
Because in Colorado you
can be as loud as you like.
Holy .
That was like a lot better than,
I mean, I've seen a lot of time.
- It's a unique experience out here.
- Holy cow, man.
I mean, that was so freaking loud.
Because even when I've seen
launches, you're a mile away.
- Yeah, we're like 200 yards.
- Yeah, that was cool.
And with that, I did Colorado
the way you're supposed to.
Guns on the way in,
glorious fire spigot on the way out.
Adam Kline in Golden Shoulders,
please play us off.
♪ I moved away from Denver, Colorado ♪
♪ And I was all alone ♪
♪ Alone, alone, alone ♪
♪ All alone ♪
♪ And I made a huge mistake ♪
♪ I moved away from Denver, Colorado ♪
♪ And I don't know why, I don't know why ♪
♪ And I was all alone ♪